[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAHESH NARAYANAN: Good
evening, everyone.
My name is Mahesh Narayanan.
I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud.
I'm joined by two other product
managers, Olivia Vautrin.
OK.
Vautrin, who is also
a product manager
at Google Cloud,
and Alim Karim, who
is a product manager at NetApp.
And they're also going to make
sure that nobody's sleeping,
so please keep your eyes open.
ALIM KARIM: Can you see us?
MAHESH NARAYANAN: They can.
I can't.
All right, hopefully
that got some laughs.
All right, so just
some housekeeping.
We have the Dory Q&A, so
if you have any questions,
please-- about the
session, please submit them
through the Dory tool.
It's an internal tool
in Google that we
use quite a lot that gives
an opportunity for everybody
to ask questions.
The catch is if you like a
question please upvote them,
so that there's a higher
probability of those questions
to be asked.
OK.
So a very simple and easy way
to connect to any Google service
is through internet.
So if you're on prem, you can
get a dedicated internet access
and connect to Google service.
If you're consuming these
services from VPC or from GCP,
whether it be a GCE
instance or a GKE cluster,
we have by default
public IPs, and you
can connect to them easily.
But there is-- a
lot of companies
have security and compliance
requirements which
mandates that you do not
use public IPs, right.
So to meet that mandate,
you have a cloud
VPN or you buy an interconnect
service from Google,
such as a dedicated interconnect
or partner interconnect.
On the GCP side, you deploy
VMs without a private IP,
or you create
private GKE clusters.
So the problem
statement now becomes,
how do you connect to
Google services privately
from on prem, as
well as from GCP.
So the agenda of this
session is to talk
about whether
different types-- what
are the different types of
managed services on Google.
And then, provide
you the solutions
that are available to connect
privately to these services.
And to round it out,
we'll have Alim talk
about how they're using
one of these solutions
to offer cloud volume
product from NetApp on GCP.
So there are primarily two
types of Google services.
The first service is hosted
on Google Infrastructure,
and it is front ended by
an internal Google proxy
from the compute resources
such as a GCE or a GKE cluster.
Examples of those services
are GCE, Google Cloud storage,
BigQuery, Cloud Spanner.
And the solution that
is available to connect
to these services privately is
called Private Google Access.
The second type
of Google service
is the one that is hosted on
the Google Cloud Infrastructure.
And we use VPC
peering as a primitive
to connect to these services.
So think of these services
as another customer
on Google Cloud.
But this happens to be a
service that Google provides.
It's hosted by Google.
Example of such
services are Cloud SQL.
If you're using GKE, then
GKE Private Clusters.
And the solution to connect
to these services privately
is called Private
Service Access.
So these are the two services.
So we looked at--
just to recap, we have two
different types of services,
one hosted on Google
Infrastructure,
the other hosted on Google
Cloud Infrastructure.
And the ones hosted on Google
Cloud infrastructure is
called Private Service Access.
The one that is hosted on Google
Infrastructure, the solution
is called Private Google Access.
I'll talk about
Private Google Access.
Olivier and Alim are going
to talk about Private Service
Access.
But before we go
into the solutions,
let's take a step back and get
a good understanding of what
a VPC is in GCP, because
that forms the basic building
block of all these services.
So in-- a VPC is basically
a customer's network
in Google Cloud.
It's a virtual network.
And it is global in nature.
What global means
is, let's say you
have a deployment in US West and
another deployment in US East,
we do not require you to
create two different VPCs.
If you have a deployment
in US East and US West,
you do not need
two different VPCs
if they want to
talk to each other.
With global VPCs,
these two deployments
can talk to each
other automatically
without any special
provisioning on your side.
We also offer VPC peering.
So if you have a VPC in
your project, in your org,
you can connect to another
VPC in the same project
or a different
project in your org,
or you can connect to another
VPC in a totally different org.
So that's what VPC
peering provides.
Now, let's talk about
Private Google Access.
We saw how internet
was not an option
to connect to these services.
So previously, it
was a simpler task
to figure out
where the service--
where the requests
to these services
were coming from, because each
customer gets a unique public
IP.
With private IP, we need to
understand which customer
is sending this request.
This black box to the
customer is a proxy,
is an internal
Google proxy, which
we call Google Cloud Front End.
So it's called a
Cloud Front End proxy.
What it does is,
like a gateway, it
connects the customer's network
to the Google Infrastructure--
the services lying on
Google infrastructure.
It understands what IPs
does a customer's VPC have
and makes sure that the
traffic is ordered back to it.
Now that we understand
the glue, let's
see what is the workflow in
setting up Private Google
Access.
So the first step
is to advertise
a specific-- a new prefix
and make DNS changes.
And this is, pretty much,
these other two steps,
whether you are on prem
or if you're on cloud,
if you are using from
a GCE or a GKE cluster.
Let's look at the
set up for on prem.
So I talked about announcing a
special prefix, a new prefix.
Why do we need that?
Well, Google APIs,
Google Services
already have a
public IP, you know.
You are routing to them
publicly on internet.
So we need a special,
or a new, prefix
that identifies the private
part to these services.
And this is called
a restricted VIP.
If you were to do an NS look
up on the restricted VIP,
you will get a slash 30 block,
which is 199.36.153.4/30.
Even though it's--
although it's a public IP,
it is not publicly routable.
OK.
So now that we have
this restricted VIP,
you can go on your Cloud
Router, which is something
that you'll be using
if you're doing
cloud VPN or an interconnect
partner or dedicated.
Create a custom route
with this slash 30 block
and announce it
over BGP to on prem.
Now, your on prem
resources have this route.
But how does the application--
how does the client
libraries know
that they need to send
traffic to this slash 30?
We obviously don't want you
to change your applications.
So the simplest way to achieve
this is through DNS, right.
And there are three
popular ways of doing this.
From on prem, you can
change the config map
to resolve start
up googleapis.com
to restrictedgoogleapis.com
If you are on GCP,
you can use the
Cloud DNS product
and, specifically, private
zone feature within Cloud DNS
to resolve the start out
Google API to a CNAME
to restrictedGoogleapis.com.
And also you can use, on
GCP, BIND or any other DNS
of your choice.
Now, if you're setting
up private connectivity
from VPC resources--
compute resources on VPC,
such as a GC or a GKE cluster,
you need to select the subnet--
there is a flag called
Private Google Access,
so you need to select that.
And then, once
you create the VM,
you ensure that
the VM is created
on this particular subnet.
Please keep in mind that
the VPC has a routing table.
And the default route
of that routing table
still says internet gateway.
So when you send
out-- with this setup,
when you send out a
request to a googleapi.com
and start a googleapi.com,
it uses the default route.
But even though it says
the internet gateway,
it's not actually--
the traffic still stays
on Google backbone.
The other step is the--
so there is also,
like, I just talked
about how there is a routing
table and the default
out points to internet gateway.
From a security
perspective, if you
want to lock down your
network, and if you
want to remove
this default route,
you can go ahead and do that.
And you can have the same 199.
36.
153.
4 slash 30 restricted VIP.
You can create a
static route with that
pointing to the default
internet gateway.
I'll reiterate, even though it
says default internet gateway,
the traffic is not
going out to internet.
It stays within Google backbone.
And any traffic in Google that
is destined towards the slash
30 restricted VIP,
Our [? SDLA ?]
is smart enough to realize
that this traffic is
destined to a service behind
the Google proxy, right.
So these are some of
the steps that you
can take to connect to services
privately using Private Google
Access.
With that, I will hand
it over to Olivier.
OLIVIER VAUTRIN: Thank you.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Perfect.
So thanks, Mahesh.
So we just looked at how do
we connect services that are
on the Google Infrastructure.
So services, such as Just
Yes, Spanner, and so on.
So we are now looking--
now going to look at
the services that are
hosted inside the Google Cloud
Infrastructure, inside GCP.
And some [INAUDIBLE]
so we are going
to the point of the segment is,
how can I access from my VPC
from a service in a VPC
to this marriage service
privately with a private
IP, and, also, how can
I do that from on prem.
So on prem to my
managed service,
without going through internet.
So services on the
GCP infrastructure
are services like Cloud SQL,
Cloud Filer, GKE Private
Master, and so on.
So who is using Cloud SQL here?
Who has already
used Cloud SQL here?
OK.
Who has used Cloud SQL
with a private IP, already?
OK.
So I see a lot of
hand for Cloud SQL
but not Cloud SQL
with a private IP.
So Cloud SQL with
a private IP is
a service that
has been launched,
I think it was
back in September.
And it's using the
functionality that I'm
going to describe right now.
OK.
So services on top of GCP are
using the same building block
that any other service on GCP,
that we are using VPC, VM,
and so on.
So you have on
the left side, you
have a consumer of
VPC, so a consumer
that would like to
use the service.
And on the right side,
we have the producer
of VPC, the producer that has
developed the service, that
is managing the service.
How do we connect to
VCPs together on GCP?
We are using VPC peering.
And that's a way we
connect privately
from a consumer to
a private producer.
The advantage of VPC
peering is, because there's
no proxy and no device
between the two VPCs,
there's direct connection
between the two VPCs.
It's high output
and very low delay,
which is very important for
database type of services.
At the same time,
the producer of VPC
is going to be unique
for each consumer of VPC.
So every time a consumer will
like to create a new service,
we are going to have a specific
producer VPC for the service
to have a security between
all those instances.
Before explaining how to use VPC
peering for the on prem going
activity, and so on, I
need to take a quick segue
and explain a new feature
that we launched for Next,
and this feature is the
capacity to exchange our custom
routes with VPC peering.
And you're going
to see later how
we are using this feature
for on prem connectivity.
In the VPC, We have
three types of routes.
We have subnet routes.
We have static routes.
And we have dynamic,
or BGP, routes.
Subnet routes are the routes
that are already automatic,
created by the system.
Static and BGP routes
are routes that
are created by the
user of the VPC, right.
And that's why we call static
and dynamic routes custom
routes, because you
can customize them.
By default, with VPC
peering, only subnet routes
are exchanged.
So by default, when
you do VPC peering,
all the subnets are exchanged,
but the static and BGP routes
are not exchanged.
So to allow the exchange of
static and dynamic routes,
we have flags that you can
update on the VPC peering.
So we have import
and export flags
on each side of the
VPC peering connection.
So that means four flags,
two on the first VPC
and two on the second VPC.
An import and export
flag on each side.
If you have an export flag
for custom route as true,
that means that
you are OK to send
those routes to your next VPCs.
If you set the flag
import as true, let
means that you are OK to learn
the routes from the others VPC.
For those of you that
are familiar with BGP,
that should be very
familiar to you.
It's very similar
to policy based
routing on typical routers.
Let's take an example.
So in this example,
I have two VPCs.
And my goal here, let's assume
that my goal is to create
routes for specific
subnets I would
like to send traffic to the VM
B that is on the right side,
right.
So I have my VM A for
specific destination
I would like to have, as a next
stop, VM B on the right side.
On GCP today, it is not possible
to create a static routes
with a next stop on another VCP.
So how do we do that without
creating a static route
with an export with a
next stop in another VPC?
So the first thing is we
need to create static routes
on the second VPC.
OK.
So let's look at the routing
table for one minute.
So on each VPC, here,
we have a subnet.
That's why we have a local route
that the subnet routes, and we
have the routes to the subnet
on the other VPC, right,
with next stop B.
So 10.30 is my local subnet.
10.40 is my subnet on VPC B.
Now that I configures the static
routes on the VPC B, I see a
third route on the right side.
I see a third route, which is
my static route with 10.100
sending traffic as
a next stop VM B.
But still it's not
enough, because on VPC A
I can still not see the routes.
So the next step is to configure
an export policy on VPC B,
so that I can say, please
export that route to VPC A.
But you can see,
it is not enough,
because even with
the export I don't
see the routes on the
routing table of VPC A.
So what is missing is
an import statement.
So an import flag as true.
If I put the import flag
as true, then suddenly
I see the static route
on my routing table.
OK.
So you can see that I need
to configure both flags
for security reasons.
So both VPCs need to
agree on what to exchange.
And once that done,
I'm exchanging
my static routes or my BGP
routes between my VPCs.
Another use case
for the exchange
of static and dynamic routes
is what we call Transit VPC.
So with Transit VPC,
let's say that I
would like to share a
VPN or an interconnect
across multiple VPCs.
I mean, obviously, a
simple way to do that would
be to have multiple VPNs.
But that would be very
complex or expensive.
So let's say that I
would like to share a VPN
or interconnect
across multiple VPCs.
So a way to do that is to have--
to create a VPC that we
will call a Transit VPC.
This VPC can be empty
or with resources in it,
and in this VPC I
am going to have
export flags on all those VPCs.
And automatically,
all my routes are
going to be exchanged between
on prem to all the VPCs here.
So it's dynamic.
So even if you change routes
on prem, automatically with BGP
and with my export
policy, all the VPCs
will be updated
with the new routes.
Some advantages
of this solution--
so there's no bandwidth limits.
It's VPC peering,
so with VPC peering
there is no bandwidth limit.
Its direct connection.
VPC peering is free,
besides the price of egress
of no more traffic usage.
So VPC peering is free.
And every type of
connectivity is supported.
So it's VPN, but it
also interconnects.
OK.
Now that we looked
at this new feature,
how to exchange routes between
all the types of routes
between my VPC, how can I do
that for my prem statements?
And my prem statements
is, again, how can
I connect from my on prem
to my managed services?
And for-- to
connect from on prem
to my managed service privately.
I need two things, I
need to exchange routes
between on prem and the VPC--
my VPC, the consumer
VPC, and I need
to exchange all those
routes between the consumer
VPC and the managed service.
OK.
So let's do that one by one.
First, I have a VPC peering
between the managed service
and the consumer
of this service.
I'm exporting all the routes
to the managed service VPC.
And then I need to configure
a customer advertisements
on the cloud router
of the consumer VPC
to send those routes to on prem.
So with those 2-step
export of routes
to the managed service VPC
and the BGP advertisements
to on prem.
I have full connectivity
end to end between the on
prem and my managed service.
OK.
But that could be a
bit complex, right.
I mean, so let's say--
let's assume that I just
want to have a Cloud SQL
instance, or, let's say,
I want to have a
simple MySQL database.
Now, suddenly, I need to
understand VPC peering.
I need to understand
export-import.
It might be a bit complex.
So how can we simplify all this?
And the way we simplify all
this is by creating a new scheme
called Private Service
Success, now in GA.
And the way to think about
Private Service Access
is it's a managed VPC
peering connection.
So when I want to
create a simple service,
like a MySQL instance,
the VPC peering connection
will be automatically
created for me, right.
All the steps will
be done for me.
So I don't need to
understand VPC peering
for a simple service connection.
So how does that
work in details?
Let us assume that I am
the owner of the VPC,
so here is a VPC green.
So let's assume that I'm
the owner of the VPC green,
and I would like to
create MySQL instance.
My first step is to decide which
IP range my service should use.
So it's to allocate a range
for all my managed services.
This wrench can be, slash 24,
can be as small as a slash 24,
or it can be
larger, because-- it
can be larger because it will be
shared across all my services.
So let's say I would like
to have 50, 100 services,
I can have a large range.
And each one of them can pick
a different IP in this range.
So we do advise to use a
large range, if possible,
that many customers
cannot have large range,
because they don't have a
lot of private IP available.
But if you can, it's better to
have a large range like a slash
16, and then every
time you create
a new service they can pick
addresses from this range.
So in this example, I'm
the owner of VPC green.
I located a slash 24.
On the right side, you can
see the UI of the Cloud SQL
creation.
And it's as simple as
clicking on private IP instead
of public IP.
So if you go to Advanced
Option on MySQL, on Cloud SQL,
there's an option on
advanced networking
to select private IP.
So when you select
private IP, it connects.
Automatically your
system is going to pick--
to create a MySQL instance in a
VPC using the rights IP range,
using a private IP in
the ranges you selected.
And we automatically create
the VPC peering for you.
Now that we gave an
example for one service,
let's take an example with two
services, or multiple services.
In this example, again I am
the owner of the green VPC,
and I would like two
services, instead of one.
Same way.
I can go in the UI
and say, I would
like to have a service
from NetApp or from Google.
And the system is going
to create, automatically,
one VPC peering per
producer of those services.
So in this case, if,
let's says, there's
two producers,
Google and NetApp.
I'm going to have a VPC
peering for each one of them.
Share VPC support.
So the issue with shared
VPC is, in this case,
there's two service
projects in my shared VPC.
So with shared VPC, I can divide
my VPC in multiple service
projects so that each team
can have different billing
and different item rights
for the resources in my VPC.
The issue with shared
VPC in this case
is typically the owner
of a service project
do not have permission to
create the VPC peering.
And so in theory they cannot--
the owner of this project
cannot create a connection
to a service, because
it will have permission,
and they need to ask you for
every creation of service.
They need to ask the permission
from the network admin--
from network admin
owner of the shared VPC.
So the way we
solve that is, yes,
for the first connection
to a service provider,
you do need to ask
for permission.
But for every other
connection, the VPC peering
is already there.
And so you don't need
to ask for permission.
So the permission is asked once
for every service provider.
And when the service provider--
when the connection has
been created to the service
provider, each owner of those
services-- of those service
projects can create instances
without asking for permission.
To summarize, Mahesh discussed
about all the services running
on the Google Infrastructure.
I discussed about
the services running
on the Google Infrastructure--
on the GCP and Google Cloud
Infrastructure.
And there is two
solutions, one for each,
for the services on the
Google Infrastructure,
like GCS, like Spanner, use
something called Private Google
Access.
The services built on GCP, like
Cloud SQL, Redis, Memchached,
or TPU, or GKE Private Master
are using Private Service
Access.
And Private Service Access
is using VPC peering.
Private Google access
is using a proxy
to separate the GCP
infrastructure and the Google
Infrastructure.
So we are now going to see how
NetApp has built their services
using Private Service
Access and how
they use VPC peering to give
a very low latency volume
application.
ALIM KARIM: Can you
guys hear me OK?
Thanks.
Thanks, Olivier.
So just a quick
show of hands, who
has heard of Cloud
Volumes and the solution
that NetApp and Google
are building together?
Marketing departments doing
something, so that's good.
So just for a recap,
what is Cloud Volumes?
What does it do?
Who's interested in it?
I'll just spend one
slide covering that.
Essentially, Cloud Volumes is a
fully managed cloud native file
services offering.
It's really meant to provide
high throughput, low latency
NFS and SMB storage.
And it's really targeted at
moving enterprise applications
that customers used to
run on premise into GCP.
So really used for
things like SAP,
or running other
enterprise applications
like content management
systems, B2B e-commerce systems,
and such.
Typically, what you'll
find is there's also
a set of industries, like
media and entertainment,
like life sciences, as well
as genomic sequencing, that
are interested in running NAS
specific applications in GCP,
and these are
basically industries
that have been using NAS
on premise for a very, very
long time and, therefore,
have tools and processes
and skill sets built around NAS.
And they want to extend
these into public cloud GCP
more specifically.
And therefore, they need
managed NAS solutions in GCP
to move these business
processes or applications over.
In terms of who's interested in
a solution like Cloud Volumes,
typically it is cloud
architects or application owners
who have been tasked
with, essentially,
either moving a business process
or an application into GCP.
And ultimately, it's
application teams
being able to then provision
and manage these NFC or SMB end
points themselves
once they're in GCP.
So on the right hand side
is a quick screenshot
of what this looks like.
Basically, it's a native
interface into GCP
through the Cloud Console.
Customers can go in
and create a volume
and essentially consume it from
either GCE or GKE instances.
So one quick slide here to show
what the architecture of Cloud
Volumes looks like.
There's a dotted line in sort of
the middle of the picture that
separates the control
plane from the data plane.
I'll talk about the
control plane quickly.
As I said, the users enter
into Cloud Volume service
through their normal pathways,
either through the Cloud
Console or using the API
and, soon coming, the CLI.
That then hits our
control plane, which
is running natively in GKE.
And that talks to other
parts of the GCP ecosystem
around authentication
for IAM, for the users
that are logging in.
Pushing metrics into
Stackdriver, logging metrics
for auditing, as
well as integration
into the billing APIs.
And essentially, from
this perspective,
the customer sees a native
volume in their GCP project.
Volumes are isolated by project.
And then these resources
are built directly
into the customer's
billing account
without having any
interaction with NetApp.
The interesting
part that pertains
to VPC peering and such is the
data path setup at the bottom.
So for every customer
that comes in
and every customer that has
a host project, basically,
we set up a VPC peer connection
between their VPC and ours,
where we provision all
of the resources that
are needed to supply all of the
NFC end points that they need.
So at the bottom
of the diagram, you
see there is a set
of Cloud Volumes
that this customer has
gone ahead and created.
These volumes exist on the
producer side, so on our side,
and then we expose mount
points, which are RFC
1918 addresses that they give us
back into their infrastructure
so that they can mount
these NFS volumes
and essentially access them
from either GCE or GKE.
So what does private services
connectivity do for us?
Really, it's three key things.
Number one is we really want
to simplify the end user
experience around that
data path setup, right.
So we just want
customers to come in
and simply peer with us
and our producer services
to be able to get access.
We want to really abstract
away all of the networking
complexities that it takes to
deliver a service from an NFS
perspective and keep
that on our side
and simply expose the other end
of a VPC peer to the customer.
With NFC applications
that I mentioned, like SAP
and some of these other
industry specific applications,
performance is a very,
very key criteria.
Most applications need
a lot of throughput
and very, very low latency.
And VPC pairing allows
us to achieve that.
And then, finally, it
gives our customers
a uniform way of accessing
these services, just
like other services like Cloud
SQL that Olivier talked about.
The second big benefit is it's
a private IP based service.
For any of you that
are familiar with NFS,
you realize that the
data that is stored
on NFS and the applications
that use NFS typically
contain sensitive,
secure data, which
means that you can't really
have public endpoints on an NFS
share.
So this essentially
allows customers
to give us their RFC 1918
addresses that they want
to see on these end points.
And then, finally, dealing with
large enterprise customers.
Over 90% of them have
a shared VPC topology.
So being able to support that
is a key requirement for us.
And again, private
services connectivity
gives us that, as well.
And as Olivier
mentioned, so this
allows us to have a one time
setup from a host project
perspective into our service.
And then all of the service
projects that follow
can then just consume
these services
without requiring
any additional setup.
[MUSIC PLAYING]